je n'ai pas besoin de vous rappeler
combien notre rôle ici est essentiel
sans nous sans notre assistance en aucun
cas l'armée afghane ne pourrait tenir
cette province
on reste avec moi
légalement la dgac demande d'accentuer
notre activité sur toute la zone
ça veut dire qu'on va rester pense qu'il
faut pas le dire au sol pas maintenant
ça risque de les pousser à bout et des
guerres craquer teulier contacter le qg
qui leur causent débrouille pour les
munitions mais qu'on crève de faim dit
va bientôt dire m avec tout le respect
que je vous dois
on devait pas repartir demain on va être
des cibles faciles pour les autres dire
qu'est ce qu'il nous reste à prouver ne
s'agit pas trouvé quoi que ce soit nous
sommes ici pour remplir une mission
c'est pas notre guerre
nous sommes et armée britannique c'est
un acte de lâcheté
l'aspect à la phase de l'ennemi je crois
que vous avez mal entendu reçu m on a
passé deux semaines à traquer les
talibans
et quand on est parti ils sont venus
aussi sec